how serious
okay for people who don't know because
you've
from a surface level fans perspective i
know you've
not threatened but you've called out any
rapper to fight any rapper i don't give
a [ __ ] who you any rapper that you ever
see threw some gloves on
and hit the mix ain't gonna say rapper
any celebrity that you see threw some
gloves on in the midst i said come on
let's set the fight up you can't say
don't nobody knows that dog you can't
say it ain't gonna sell out like it's
gonna sell out so house how uh
i guess like how serious did your boxing
career actually get to like the highest
point that it actually i'm actually the
first rapper to ever in history gopro
i'm actually a pro fighter which is my
hand's license but the thing is is i did
that first pro fight knocked his ass out
in the fourth round it was a good fight
well no easy fight people see the video
and they'd be like oh snap you was
fighting somebody who was oh if you was
at that fight you knew like there was no
easy fight like i had [ __ ] the room was
so sold out like soda baby was there too
the room was so [ __ ] filled like
people were scared people was like snap
you had me nervous for a minute bro you
was letting him hit you i'm like bro
it's boxing my [ __ ] like let's check
y'all can't look at me like floyd you
feel my checkers man it's boxing but we
got the knockout or whatever but
that [ __ ] definitely is it's serious
cause you gotta you gotta tune in and
tune everything out bro like especially
i didn't go fight somebody off the
street or a weak [ __ ] i know i
can beat i want to go fight an
undefeated [ __ ] since you're pro
if you fight someone like a street fight
can't you nope is it i can whoop your
way so it they they won't like they
won't look at you like you're you're
fighting somebody with deadly weapons
yeah no you putting your hands on me
okay i don't know
i get to defend myself
for sure you should get in and spar with
uh d smoke
yeah whatever they want to do brother
[ __ ] gonna make one who that's that how
big is he bro
he's shorter he's like uh
he's probably wider than you like he's
more probably how much he weigh like i'm
123.
he weighs more than you he probably
weighs like 150. 160. hell no they not
my coaches when he let me do that but i
mean just just just a special sparrow
because he's a good guy you're a good
you can definitely we definitely just he
just bought um him and g parico just
bought uh the broadway boxing gym in l.a
no we i definitely we just sparring we
we do that all day